And now the old scout master.
It was a big international event, and the camping areas assigned to the different units that were there were pretty tight,
And so the leaders of this particular troop made it clear to the scouts that they should not walk through anyone else's campsite.
And so, not long after they had made this clear,
a gentleman in full Swedish scout uniform walked straight through their camp, just like he owned the place,
And the youngest scout, who was eager to impress everyone and who wanted to indicate that he remembered the conversation about not walking through another person's camp,
told this gentleman in no uncertain terms that he was not to walk through their campsite.
And the gentleman, of course, apologized and moved on.
And then the scout looked over at the adults, you know, as if to say, hey, you know, I remembered and I told this guy.
But they weren't quite so thrilled with the younger scout, because the gentleman he had told was actually the king of Sweden who was out touring the camp.
Oh dear Hey. this is podcast number 163..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green. Just a couple of quick announcements before we get started.
Sunday April 14th is our next scout circle,
And the scout circle is a live presentation with a question and answer period,
And that is going to be with our guest, Kevin Callan, who is an author and a canoe guide and canoe enthusiast and an outdoorsman,
And I think you'll really enjoy listening to Kevin and then you'll have a chance to ask him questions.
Go to scoutscircleorg in order to find out how to participate in that,
And then on April 14th, from 9 to 10 pm Eastern Standard Time, we'll have Kevin Callan on as our guest.
And the next thing is this:
It's getting towards the end of March.
If your troop is like mine, you've just welcomed a bunch of new scouts who have come up from their weebillos den
And they're going to be looking for gear.
Wouldn't it be great if you could send them to somebody who knew what to get, who'd been a scout leader for a number of years
and had seen boys work their way through a bunch of stuff and knew exactly what kind of gear worked best,
what saved you money and what was going to last?
I've got news for you. That guy does exist.
His name's Bill Fleming and he's on the phone with me right now from ConahoeCreekcom.
Hey Bill,
Hello Clark, How you doing?
I'm good, Bill. you've been a scout leader for eight or 10 years. Is that right?
That is correct. We'll be starting our 10th year in May.
Tell us a little bit about the gear bundle that you've put together at ConahoeCreekcom
and how that's going to save everybody a little heartache.
Well, the heartache can come from two directions:
Not only getting cheap gear that's not going to serve you well,
but also going out and buying expensive gear that's not going to serve you well
or that's unnecessary for what you're going to be doing.
Over the years we've kind of watched this and that's kind of generated this idea
of putting together this basic outdoor gear bundle that we have at ConahoeCreekcom.
We've catered it towards someone just getting into scouting.
We're flexible about the components, so if you are a little bit more experienced,
we'll be glad to swap out some of those features for you to meet your needs.
Obviously, one size doesn't fit all.
One set of camping gear isn't going to work in every part of the country.
but Bill knows what to get and how to get it and how to save you some money too.
And you can save a little bit more by using the discount code
for the listeners to the Scoutmaster podcast, CG113..
Go to ConahoeCreekcom-
C-O-N-O-H-O-Creekcom.
Thanks a lot, Bill,
Thank you, Clark, and we'll see you at the creek.
So in this podcast we're going to talk a little bit about the difference
between planning and preparation in Scout Master Ship in seven minutes or less.
Then we've got an email question to answer.
That's going to take care of the rest of the podcast.
so let's go ahead and get started, shall we
Scout Master Ship in seven minutes or less?
So the Patrol Leaders Council sits down,
They plan.
Then they get up from the table and they have their plans written down
And the assumption is that the Scouts are going to start preparing.
They'll go home and they'll pour over their Scout Handbook
and, you know, take notes and look things up online
and spend a whole lot of time preparing for that next meeting,
Getting things ready right.
Then we get to the next meeting and we find out,
oh, they really didn't do too much of that, did they?
So I'm going to mention this again.
I think I mentioned it recently,
But we've started to differentiate between the idea of planning
and preparation in our Patrol Leaders Council meetings
And we do it this way:
The planning part, that's easy, okay,
That's who's going to do what and when they're going to do it
and what day it's going to happen.
That's a piece of cake.
You need 10 minutes to do that for a month's full of meetings really.
The preparation part is usually where everything falls apart,
because they don't do this in the context
of a Patrol Leaders Council meeting. necessarily.
They're sitting around a table somewhere,
They're coming up with a plan and then they're talking
about the television show that they saw last night
or the video game that they're playing,
And then they work on the plan a little bit more
and then they switch back to something else.
And you know, remember being 14 or 15?
You know, if you thought of something, it was planned,
Basically planning at the speed of thought.
So what we're missing sometimes, I think,
in this youth-led paradigm
where the Scouts are planning and presenting everything,
where they're thinking things through,
is the fact that they don't really think things through.
So if I have a 14- or 15-year-old Scout
preparing to instruct his troop or Patrol on orienteering,
he'll think this.
He'll think I'll be instructing everybody
about how to do orienteering.
I've done orienteering in the past,
I have a compass and I'll find a map or something
and we're ready to go.
What more do I need to do
When it comes time to demonstrate
any skill associated with orienteering
and instruct others.
out comes the compass and the map
and he's going to stand there
and the other Scouts are going to look on
and he's going to try and remember how to orient a map
and he maybe really hasn't understood what he's doing.
and he opens his handbook
and he's reading the instruction
and in the meantime the dozen Scouts
that he's trying to work with,
their attention is elsewhere.
They're talking or asking questions,
They're bored.
The whole thing devolves into that familiar chaos
we all know so well
because they didn't do much of anything.
Now, any adult looking on
is going to have an almost uncontrollable urge
to step in and save the Scout
and ask for the compass and the map
and show everybody how to do this themselves.
We're going to decide that this whole
boy-led idea
and this idea of Scouts instructing
and planning things
Well, this just doesn't work.
So we're going to take over
and we can avoid this, I think,
by being very intentional
about helping our Scouts get through
the preparation stage.
Now, you don't need to do this every single time
a Scout is preparing something,
but think of it as a little bit of that
on-the-job training,
that is a little bit of mentoring
We need to lead them to discover
how to prepare
and how to instruct. well,
by asking questions.
So here's an example of what I'm talking about.
Let's say the Patrol Leaders Council meeting
is over. It was fairly simple.
It took 10, 15, 20 minutes maybe,
And they established
the structure and the content
and the plan for their activities.
And now it's time to prepare.
Using my example,
I'm going to be instructing his fellow Scouts
on orienting a map,
And he sits down with me
so I can coach him through the preparation process.
And I'll do this
by asking him a question.
So what are you going to need to make this happen?
And he'll say:
do you have one?
And
that's the point where he'll probably say,
yeah, I don't know,
Maybe we have one somewhere
And maybe we spend
a few minutes finding one
in the Scout Closet or something.
And then
I would ask-
let's say it's next week
and you're the instructor
and I'm a Scout- show me what happens next.
And my Scout
is going to kind of stand there for a second
and he's going to say:
well, I'm not sure
what I'm going to do next.
And I said: well,
you need to show me how to orient a map.
And well, okay, well, here's the compass
and the map and you do this.
Wait a minute. wait a minute,
I know how to do this.
I'm going to ask him the question:
what are the Scouts doing at this point?
And he's probably going to tell me that they have
pretty much so lost interest
and gone right through the scenario.
So I'm going to walk him through this
question wise.
Hey, where is it written down about how to orient a map?
Well, maybe it's in the Scout Handbook.
Hey, do we have one of those? Yeah,
Alright, so let's see what we can do here
Now. are you going to remember all this
when you're getting ready to do this next time?
Oh sure, Yeah,
I said. well, is there any way you can kind of
store this in a memory somewhere
so that you will actually remember it?
Yeah, well, maybe I could write some of it down.
Okay, so now,
in the space of
maybe 15 or 20 minutes,
I've asked a lot of questions
and now he has, like a reasonably good
handle on what he needs to do.
He's beginning to work things out.
Maybe he's even taking a few notes
and writing things down. you know,
I didn't tell him anything,
I just asked questions
and I helped him discover things for himself.
And I think in doing this
we've not only helped him
through that particular process.
we've been
starting to impart a skill to him
that he's not likely going to forget.
Once a scout's been
coached through that process a couple of times,
he'll be a self-starter.
He'll anticipate and answer the questions
for himself,
And when he's instructing his fellow scouts
things won't decay into chaos
maybe quite so quickly.
They'll just be that low roar of activity
and learning that looks like chaos
to the adult eye. We could, in theory,
take all of our older scouts and set up
a how to instruct training session,
but I like the idea of
mentoring with something that is
actually related
to something he needs to do.
right then, If we just set up
that kind of how to instruct training session
and do that once a year or something,
that's just another adult
talking to him about things that they don't really attach
to any kind of actual
need to know. If we coach
and mentor them with an actual
rather than theoretical task in mind,
there's a sense of utility
about that coaching that makes
it more valuable to them and actually
helps them to learn a new skill.
So think about
separating planning and preparation.
Think about pointing out the
importance of good preparation.
Ask questions and coach a scout
through the process of preparation
And pretty soon he'll be able to do it
all by himself.
Write me a letter,
send it by name
Email. that is, folks.
And here's an answer to one of your
emails.
I heard from Carl Smith,
who is with Troupe 603
out in Cave Creek, Arizona,
and he asked me this question.
he says our troop has for many years
assimilated new scouts like
Weeblos who cross over into the pack
by putting them in their own new patrol
and because of that our patrols
are pretty much divided by age.
There are some benefits to this type
of patrol structure, but several
of the assistant scout masters feel the boys
are missing out on one of the most
important aspects of scouting:
older boys leading younger boys.
We have a buy-in from our current
scout master to reorganize patrol
so that each patrol has a strong mix
of older and younger boys,
but he wants a detailed
plan on how we will both execute
this as well as handle some of the
potential rough spots.
We have a troop of about 80 boys.
about 35% of them
are older and about 50%
of them are younger,
So I'm looking for some advice.
What's the best way to reassign
boys to new patrols.
Should we make sure to put a NYLT
trained boy in each patrol?
Should we distribute the reliable older boys
amongst the patrols?
Number two is many of the patrols
have been together for years.
We are making this change.
Number three is several of the older boys
only attend meetings sporadically.
How do we handle the situation where a patrol
has none of its older boys there
to lead the younger boys?
And number four: because of this change,
we feel the new patrols will need some
guidance while they learn
the ropes. How should we do this?
Remember we have 10 plus patrols
and we do not have that many
assistant scout masters.
Any other guidance or advice would be:
Carl, I wouldn't recommend
changing your patrols
around
like you're suggesting,
unless the patrol leaders council says
that they think it changes in order.
After all, it is their troop and they ought
to be able to figure things out like this
for themselves. As a scout master
with our troop, I don't have anything
to do with who is in what patrol.
I don't assign scouts to patrols
and frankly, I don't really care
if a patrol has 10 members or 4
or what their ages are.
Every once in a while,
the senior patrol leader will come to me
for advice on handling a patrol
or maybe resetting all the patrols in the troop,
And I always tell him the best thing
to do is to get together with the scouts
and let them decide who goes where.
If he runs into a problem
he can always ask my advice. but
I don't really get that all that often.
This works well for us because
basically we understand that boys join
scouting to be with their friends
on camping trips and at patrol and troop meetings.
They make up patrols without
a whole lot of fuss and bother
and when we have a new group joined
from Weeblos usually they choose
to stay together more often than not
and they may spend the whole of their years
in the troop in the same patrol together.
Most older boys aren't interested
in being in a patrol with younger boys
now. they're happy to instruct them
and to help out, but they really
want to be in a patrol with their friends.
I'm not interested in coercing
them to lead. I asked
if they would care to
and the ones who are interested
say yes and the others
do what they can to help and somehow
it all works out. Now you sent me this question
just after we welcomed a new
group of Weeblos into our troop.
My two junior assistant scout masters
agreed to work with them for the next few months
to get them going. They all elect
a new patrol leader every month so that
they can learn a little bit about how a patrol works.
I asked these junior assistant scout masters
to work with these, these scouts,
with the idea that by the time summer camp
comes around they'll be functioning as
a patrol on their own. I'll have
an 11 year old patrol leader and he'll do
just fine. We've had many others
who did pretty well too. As for
adults- kind of helping patrols
out, I don't let adults get anywhere
near patrols. as a rule,
Boys automatically defer to adults
when they are around and the adults
end up leading more than the scouts.
When we're meeting or camping,
our adults are a respectable
distance away from scouts, observing
rather than participating in the activity.
We are there if they are
needed, but they don't seem
to need us very much. to tell you the truth,
Patrols camp in their own area.
they cook their own food. they looked after
each other. Many times I've been on a
camp out without ever going into the
patrol areas at all. So all this
goes to point out that scouts
can form their own patrols, elect
their own leaders and do just about everything
short of writing checks and driving themselves
back and forth to camping trips.
The fewer things we do to interrupt
or interfere with that process,
the more capable they become
at doing it for themselves. I sent
that answer off and Carl wrote back
and he said: that's an awesome reply,
exceptionally insightful. I hope you don't mind
if I share your reply with some of our
assistant scout masters and our scout master.
I have only one thing to add:
nearly everything you pointed out that
scouts should be doing we
currently have adults doing, and that's a
big problem. Many of that
established guard believes
that we have a well running troop
and they're quite resistant to changing
anything. It runs well,
of course, because the adults are running
much of it, But I believe we need to change.
maybe we should start somewhere else
and leave the patrols alone for now.
As you may imagine, Carl,
I couldn't agree with you more Obviously.
you're doing something right with a troop of
80 plus boys. Now maybe the thing
to do is to look at the way
that things are being run
and see if, by applying
the patrol method- and that'll begin with
some discussions with the adult
leadership, probably returning to a lot
of the things that you've heard through training
and things like that.
You get the scout master handbook out
and the boy scout handbook and
especially the senior
patrol leader handbook. That's kind of a
rare item but you can find one at
your scout shop and I'd even
suggest working the patrol method. It's
a book that you'll find on our website.
Once you have a commitment out of the adults
to make this change, it'll take a little while.
there'll be some chaotic times
and there'll be times where you're pretty sure it's
not going to work. But in the end,
if you stay committed to it
and you are
determined to make it happen, it will
work. Thanks for being in touch, Carl.
You can send me
an email question and you'll find out how
to do that in just a moment.
Thank you,
Music.
Hey, thanks so much for listening
to this edition of the scout master podcast.
Here's how you can keep in touch. Read
the blog at scoutmastercgcom.
There you can subscribe
to receive updates to the
blog by email. You can subscribe
to this podcast- the scout master podcast-
on iTunes and you can also
access the podcast on
your mobile device through Stitcher Smart
Radio, and you can get details about
how to make that happen at stitchercom.
You can experience
the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of
social media outlets. Follow
us at scoutmasterblog on Facebook.
You can tweet us at scoutmastercg
on Twitter, and we do have
a scoutmastercg circle
over on Google+. If all
else fails, send me an email. Yep,
that's right. You can email me
at clarkclarke
at scoutmastercgcom.
That's
clarkclarke
at scoutmastercgcom.
The
scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast are not
official publications of the Boy Scouts
of America, nor are they
endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts
of America. No, it's just me talking
into a microphone, trying to lend a hand
to scout leaders and perhaps have a
little bit of fun along the way.
Here's our founder, Sir Robert
Baden-Powell. Sir Robert,
Good luck to you
and group camping
Why? thank you, sir, Until next time.